we have some breaking news from
generation z
cnn business reports that gen zers or
zoomers
as we are now calling them have gone on
tick tock to say
skinny jeans side parts and the crying
emoji are
dead no yeah
yeah they do they say this is like all
for old people
they don't get to just get rid of skinny
jeans and
as a side part i'm sorry i still i'm
still going to use the cry emoji
sorry gen z what are they they're
zoomers
and my daughter called me a boomer the
other day
and i said i'm actually not a boomer um
i'm a uh gen xer
and um and then i my eyes started
crossing and she lost interest and
that's where that conversation went
but what about this story i mean are you
gonna stop you always do a middle part
right they say that's the cool thing to
do did you ever do a side part
i love rocking a side part every time i
rock a side part i think why don't i do
this all the time
yeah i it's by the way as just someone
who's over here i think a side part is
fun
all right um i think that nobody can
decide
for you what's dead or not that's a
personal choice
yes but if you want to know what the
kids are up to they're saying these
things aren't cool anymore
i know and now you're supposed to do
that like skull emoji where you're like
dad you killed me i'm dead oh by the way
i'm really glad that you told me that
because i didn't know what that was for
that means like omg
i'm dead and even though i i i'm still
going to use that emoji i do feel cool
knowing this
you know i i i well rossi you're in the
cool you get with the skull and cross
you know what's going on
yeah i mean look at me i'm totally cool
[Laughter]
all right thanks uh well you know we got
some more news
about feet just when you wanted them a
quick poll
wearing socks to bed do you love it or
do you think it's insane
i can't do it i'm too claustrophobic i
can't deal i don't even
my worst nightmare is the sheets tucked
in at the bottom
i'm like i just went to foot prison i'm
freaking out
but i think this is a nightmare going to
this bed with socks on
i i like to have my feet like out of the
cover kick out
on top well cosmopolitan reports a
doctor on tick tock weighed in on this
uh it's a real foot fight take a look
let's talk about people that wear socks
to bed
so wearing socks makes your feet warm
and this opens up the blood vessels that
cools the body down
the body being cool tells the brain that
it's time for bed so
actually people that wear socks tend to
fall asleep faster
is this true so we should be wearing
socks so i should put socks on while i'm
taking my melatonin
do you want to be having socks in bed
you know what
i'd rather stay awake understood
you know what also just grosses me out
what it like
just when people just like leave only
the socks on like i'm sorry just
you're naked just take the damn socks
[Music]